what if this is a dream
can you guys do any tricks to prove I'm
not dreaming Winona Ryder not dreaming
how's this for a trick
no feet yep there's the evidence they
don't believe her she's got photos
Barbara here's the pick Back in Black as
Lydia Dietz while on set in London for
Beetlejuice too I mean that is something
check out the actress sitting in a car
channeling her character and even
bringing back those iconic bangs
I myself am strange and unusual
it's a really great character but you
know she's real
you know she's like you know when you
get in those moods where you're really
you feel really dramatic and you just
sigh all the time well she's like that
all the time and the top she's wearing
it's giving us total Wednesday Addams
Vibes which might be on purpose you guys
are making me nauseous
not in a good way yeah Wednesday herself
Jenna Ortega's confirmed to play
Winona's daughter in the sequel it just
felt appropriate we also know Michael
Keaton's resurrecting his role as the
Ghost with the most
images Beetlejuice
[Music]
Beetlejuice
it's the most creative of all the movies
I've done and so is Catherine O'Hara
reprising her part as Lydia's eccentric
stepmother Delia Dietz I play uh I guess
a bad stepmother misdirected
ill-directed uh
woman who thinks she's an artist and and
was just too defensive and too insecure
and too much of a nut case to succeed at
anything
including being a mother or a stepmother
or wife
but I'm trying if you don't let me cut
out this house and make it my own I will
go and stay
Tim Burton returns to direct there's no
way they could do a Beetlejuice sequel
without doing whatever they want would
you like to be a part of it
well I am a part of it so whether I'm
part of it or not it's of course it's a
part of me and uh you know we'll see
what happens I mean it's it's something
special to me Justin thoreau's also
joining the cast as a yet to be
announced character
God you guys really are dead
this is amazing Beetlejuice 2 hits our
screens September 6 2024 and while fans
are dying to learn the sequels plot
Warner Brothers is keeping that six feet
under for now that
is why I won't do two shows a night
anymore babe I won't
[Music]